ici on circule beaucoup les dionysiens
s'y promènent aussi avec les enfants ou
en amoureux
mais on a tendance à se tromper on croit
être sur le boulevard lancastel alors
qu'il s'agit du boulevard gabriel macé
fait-on également la confusion lorsqu'on
évoque le souvenir de celui ci lui donna
son nom est ce que gabriel macé samedi
quelque chose n'a pas du tout quelqu'un
de lille qui attendent de la réunion
quoi personnage politique quelconque
je vais bien connu l'ancien maire il a
été l'un des plus grands promoteurs de
la pétanque gabriel macé avait une
grande maison au port pointe des galets
et en tant que maire dé en tant qu'homme
c'était un homme de coeur un homme
social
si vous pouviez ses cabrioles matisse ça
m'intéresserait marie emile gabriel macé
est né à saint-denis le 1er juin 1906
après ses études de droit il épouse en
marie thérèse martin dont il aura cinq
enfants deux ans plus tard il rachète
une étude de notaire au cours de la
deuxième guerre mondiale il s'engage aux
côtés des pétainistes
un choix qu'il traînera tout au long de
sa vie politique comme un boulet pendant
dix ans il est conseiller général à
saint joseph
en 1959 il abandonne le sud et remporte
au deuxième tour les élections
municipales de saint denis sur la liste
unac union nationale d'administration
communal devant le parti communiste il a
bénéficié du soutien de l'église
malgré ce succès son nom est toujours
dernier sur les listes ce qui lui vaut
le surnom de mascella que donné par ses
opposants
gabriel macé ne semble jamais dans le
bon camp ses adversaires communistes
enfants le champion de la fraude
électorale
à tel point qu'il donne sa démission et
celle de son conseil municipal le 18
septembre 1960 sa réélection deux mois
plus tard sera controversé pire ces
élections aux postes de députés en
novembre 1962 puis de nouveau à la
mairie en mars 1965 seront invalidés
gabriel macé meurt d'une longue maladie
le 12 février 1968 à son domicile de la
rue de nice à saint denis
you go